- We are back now, Kelly
always closes out the show
with a story off social media
that'll leave you with a smile.
Here's one of mine.
(upbeat music)
So TikTok is full of musical talent,
but few are as unique or as
popular as the dad from Oklahoma
who uses a talk box to duet
with his three adopted children.
It's gotten him over
11 million subscribers.
Let's take a look.
(classical music)
(crowd clapping)
Let's get that musical miser up in here.
Say hi to Jason.
(crowd cheering)
Jason are you there?
- Yes, it's so good to be here.
- Now. Now this all started as a way
to bring your family together, right?
- Yes, indeed.
My family, me and my wife
tried to start a family
and we ran into some fertility issues.
So my wife dragged me
kicking and screaming
into the concept of doing
adoption through foster care.
And while we were doing foster care,
we had 11 children come through our home
and we adopted three of them.
And one of the things
was that I kind of strike
an imposing figure when I opened the door
(host laughs) and this kids come through.
And so we used music to kind of,
that was the universal
language for the kids
that brought us all all together.
So I used music.
We sang in the car, we
sang in front of the TV
and it kind of gave the
kids a place to feel safe,
a place to feel at home
- [Host ] Now. And, how did TikTok
come into the whole picture?
- Okay. So TikTok started because
as a paraeducator in
special education department
at the school, and these kids were using
all these references.
These pop culture references
I had no idea about.
And so I said, where'd
you get this stuff from?
They said, "Go check it out on TikTok."
And when I finally found
out that it was an app,
I went and downloaded it.
And I just saw this explosion
of creativity out there
with all these kids, all these adults
just using it to find their voice.
And I thought, Hey
I can make some content
and see what happens.
And I did not anticipate the
big explosion that we have now
but yeah, because of that
I was able to connect with
a great community of people
that just love music, love my family
and just love the story
of how we came together.
And it's just been an
awesome thing for us.
- Oh my God.
That's, that's so incredible.
Jason, I'm liking your post right now.
But that's not all you get
more than just a heart.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the makers of FriXion
the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show wanna celebrate
those creating fearlessly, just like you.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
(crowd cheering)
- This is so awesome.
- My gosh.
You are as most welcome and
you are the absolute best.
I mean what an incredible story Jason.